[Music]
question party is very simple you guys
in the audience are going to ask me and
tara questions and we are going to
answer them yeah and it's going to be
fun like a party so if you have a
question just raise your hand and if we
call on you stand up and ask him ask it
nice and loud so we can hear you but
don't you pull that mask down we want
your questions not your aerosol droplets
okay so let's do this who has a question
for me and tyric
okay
tall fast hand up in the back hi hat guy
i'm a hat person and i hi what are you
drinking what am i drinking
oh fool
i'm drinking a margarita i'm always
drinking a margarita
margarita oh what time what kind of
tequila's in the margarita now i'm sorry
i called you a fool for it is i who is
the fool
it is always a patron
why because i love rap music from the
90s
i don't know why that is um that's what
i'm drinking tarik always gets a fake
margarita i am that's nothing but lime
juice oh uh i mean air yeah well it's uh
it's [ __ ] is what it is
it's great at a lot of things
not drinking although you might be for
all you know uh i might be the world's
greatest drinker you might be the
funnest drunk dude
terry it might be i might have
superpowers if i get drunk you might uh
might save the world you might you know
it's not gonna happen what me getting
drunk okay
who has another question this lady going
like this hey hi lady hello it's another
bartender related questions
when is the nbc store gonna get the
full-size amber margarita glasses
because we like to be having date nights
on friday we watch amber we drink
margaritas but we have the tiny little
glasses girl you ain't says [ __ ] she
said
when are we gonna have big margarita
glasses at the store and i'm like i
i
i love these glasses and i think they're
beautiful and everyone should buy at
least four
but this is for like
normal people um you if you look down
here
you can see that i need two
i'm i'm still at my job
i'm still i'm on the clock
but this is not this doesn't this is not
enough
this guy these two guys together okay
now you're doing something but this
this is for like dainty drinkers okay so
yeah the answer to your question is i
don't know girl but i fear you
you guys that is all the time we have
for question party this was great should
we do it again sometime
all right
see you later alligators
[Applause]
you